bis der arzt ab heute schärfer
gedownloadet geil so leute jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt ich bin vorbereitet auf das
schlimmste das geschäft kurz ab hey was
geht ab märz willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht's gut ich weiß ich sie heute
irgendwie sehr rathaus also auch so mit
dem kranken und ich muss mal dringend
wieder zum friseur
aber man muss ja auch sagen wir machen
heute einen test das ganze muss ja auch
seriös rüberkommen
leute ich bin auch wieder ganz gespannt
ist wahrscheinlich habt ihr schon
gelesen es geht nämlich heute um ein
neues produkt und service könnte es sein
als ein tablet
wenn ich das schon sehr kriegen schon so
viel hier mit diesem bunten muster hier
stehen auch direkt schon schön auf made
in china deute ich habe das ganze vor
ungefähr 12 wochen bestellt und das ist
jetzt setzt uns angekommen
wir schauen uns natürlich immer erst mal
das produkt an das ding hat mich nur 39
euro gekostet komischerweise kostet ist
jetzt 43 euro ich hab halt nur 39 euro
für bezahlen inklusive 17 euro express
versand und schnäppchen ist dann auch
wieder was anderes na gut das ist immer
ein tablet also wir haben ihr tablet 7
quad-core kib children tablet ich glaube
beschreiben den titel auch einfach nur
so keywords ja alles mögliche bomben
rein muss chronologisch eigentlich gar
keinen sinn ergeben kriterien müssen wir
alle bescheid acht gigabyte android 4.0
learning tablet eu klarer war
ich habe das in was hab ich das bestellt
ich glaube ich habe es wirklich in pink
bestellt also wir haben hier an sich ein
tablet für kinder entscheiden was
sicherlich jetzt nicht die beste
leistung hat ich war ein 8 gb android
ich glaube nicht dass das der acht
gigabyte arbeitsspeicher sind sondern
eher der gesamt speicher wir schauen uns
einfach mal kurz hier ein paar daten an
ist auch immer ganz wichtig damals habe
ich mir schon fast gedacht also acht
gigabyte speicher ja ein schönes
geschenk für kinder
und es hilft kinder beim lernen und
eltern können app installieren die das
ganze sozusagen überwacht so also ich
glaube das sind bis jetzt die
wichtigsten infos so sieht's aus ca 19 x
12 cm ist das groß
an sich wirkt das jetzt so auf den fotos
so gut bin ich auch schon so gewohnt die
satten wecken natürlich immer cooler als
sie eigentlich sind
aber da habe ich noch irgendwas
vergessen also werden auch mit dual
kamera also eine ganz normale kam nach
vorne und auch eine face kam ja das ist
jetzt das erste produkt wozu es noch gar
keine bewertungen gibt ich weiß nicht ob
das daran liegt weil die von grund auf
scheiße sind die bewertung oder weil es
doch wirklich niemand bewertete aber
bewertung gibt es nicht deswegen kann
ich da und leider durch zwar lesen hast
hier gibt es noch 14 23 euro wir wollen
hier bei euch so lange gesucht wenn mich
jetzt nicht alles täuscht ist das
zumindest von den fotos ja jetzt
komplett das gleiche wenn man nur dieses
foto vergleich mit diesem foto hier
einmal vielleicht ganz kurz die fotos in
dem lande haben wir eigentlich eins zu
eins dasselbe produkt ne hier haben wir
sogar bewertungen sehr gut funktioniert
einwandfrei und schneller versand
also das sind so sachen das kann ich
halt überhaupt nicht verstehen sowie das
ich jetzt hier ein bisschen vom thema
abschweifen
aber das ist für mich dann immer ein
sonnen großes rätsel bekommt man dann
wenn man jetzt dieses produkt für 23
euro bestellt das gleiche gerät bekommt
man dann ganz anderes gerät was gar
nicht so aussieht
ich habe keine ahnung comicartig will
gar nicht weiter aber nicht auf die
folter spannen
wir starten mit dem produkt so sieht's
aus also habe ich ja schon gesagt das
hat mich 39 euro kostet ich würd mal
sagen wenn man ein halbwegs vernünftiges
tablet für zuhause haben möchte sollte
man dafür schon so um die 150 euro
mindestens bezahlt ihr haben als ich war
ein drittel davon natürlich soll es auch
mehr für kinder sein
wir schauen jetzt mal was das kann ich
teste das wie ich alle anderen sachen
auch taste und ich wünsche euch
natürlich wieder ganz viel straße an
dieser stelle gerne mal noch nach oben
für weitere produkttests also leute
jetzt war hier die ganze verpackung ich
habe es ja gerade schon angedeutet wenn
man sich jetzt mal so dass die seien
hiervon anschaut das kommt für mich das
kommt für mich auf den ersten blick so
rüber als wäre das ding schon ziemlich
alt also wirklich so boa 2012 wenn nicht
sogar noch älter ich meine die hälfte
der logos hier wo dann glaube ich schon
wieder durch neue logos ersetzt wir
haben auch kleine macken in der
verpackung aber dann würde ich mal gar
nicht meckern ich meine das kommt aus
china hatten langen weg hinter sich hat
er gut überstanden
ja so jetzt machen wir das ganze mal auf
haben wir ein bisschen schutzfolie ich
habe es mir eigentlich ein bisschen
größer vor
bestellt um ehrlich zu sein auf jeden
fall haben wir hier direkt das produkt
in pink habe ich bestellt meine
lieblingsfarbe gut das beste kommt zum
schluss deswegen sehe ich das mal kurz
zur seite die beschreibung 1 200 und 1
des android ladekabel ich ziehe jetzt
immer mit ne also davon habe ich
wirklich schon unmengen wenn wir welche
haben wollt kommt gern vorbei klingt
einfach bei mir dann gebe ich euch ein
paar mit dann haben wir hier noch so ein
verbindungskabel usb und hier dann
irgendwie noch ein anderes kabel was das
jetzt genau sein soll weil sie noch
nicht aber es kann gut sein dass das
ladegerät ist
ansonsten weiß ich nicht was es sein
sollte naja gut also das war's
verpackung ist leer und eine marke von
den dingen steht gar nicht drauf
keine ahnung so machen wir uns an den
wichtigsten part so sieht's aus ja was
ist eigentlich sogar und wenn ich das
jetzt hier sehr ist es auf jeden fall
das gerät was mir auch auf den fotos
gezeigt wurde
das fühlt sich ja die qualität die
qualität von der verpackung wenn ich
hier über streif fühlt sich ein bisschen
komisch an nicht aber immer so ganz aber
habt ihr das auch oder wenn man halt
immer so bestimmtes papiergeld ist bei
mir so und ja hier immer eine kamera die
eine kamera ganz leise jetzt schauen wir
ob es direkt angeht das war ganz cool
ja gehts oder
[Musik]
ich denke hier gerade ein horrorfilm an
oder ist es dass dinge das finde ich
aber wirklich kommen wir haben jetzt
wieder hier 64 prozent geladen
bei fast allen elektronischen sachen die
ich jetzt so aus china bestellt habe die
sind schon geladen
soweit ich weiß war das bei meinen
iphones nie so auf ihren ein extrem
spannender hintergrund was passiert
jetzt nehmen kamera passt dass der hilfe
ach du scheiße schnell zurück ich hoffe
ihr könnt das einigermaßen gut sehen was
ich hier gerade mache welchem film ist
leider nicht wirklich kein besonders
großes tablet also wenn ich jetzt mal
den bildschirm hier habe mein iphone
unternehmen heute kommt das ungefähr bei
dem gleichen haus also wieso dann ein
tablet kaufen wenn smartphones genauso
groß sind zumal man hier jetzt
entschuldigen kann dass es
wahrscheinlich aus dem jahr 2012 stammt
da gab es auch keinen iphone 7 + leute
ich bin mir hat alles am einstellen
versuche es zumindest
ich habe jetzt schon zum zweiten mal
meine sachen eingegeben um zum beispiel
mal die youtube app store downloaden
das ding ist das stürzt immer ab fast
noch mal gucken ob sie da passiert man
muss aber sagen der touch ist ganz okay
das funktioniert alles und jetzt geht's
okay also die wären ja ganz klar damit
dass wir ein handy haben für kinder das
heißt eigentlich sollte man damit ja
natürlich lernen können aber auch
spieler spielen ich installiere hier
mein früheres lieblingsspielzeug servers
könnt gerne alle meine daumen nach oben
da lassen wenn ihr das schon mal
gespielt hatte hatte ich jetzt hier
bestimmt schon so eine minute und das
ist noch gar nicht angefangen zu
downloaden
das ist dann immer so dumm im schnitt
weil man halt so viel unnötiges zeug
aufnimmt ich stelle es aber mal hierhin
und melde mich wenn der download
abgeschlossen ist ja jetzt ok also auf
jetzigen stand kann ich das ding auch
keins empfehlen könnte während server
jetzt hier gerade im hintergrund
installiert wird
schauen wir uns mal kurz ein youtube
video an das versuche ich jetzt einfach
mal über den browser abzuspielen weil
ich habe keinen bock jetzt noch mal eine
halbe stunde zu warten bis sich diese
scheiß youtube herunter geladen habe
deswegen vielleicht klappt es ja also an
die dir schreiben macht auch mal lauter
ist vollste stufe lauter geht es leider
nicht der sound hat so ein leichtes
stolpern
ich weiß ja aber das gehört hat hört man
bisschen genau drauf
also es hängt irgendwie so ein bisschen
business server gedownloadet geil so
leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ich bin
vorbereitet auf das schlimmste das check
noch kurz ab so das sieht ja schon mal
ganz in ordnung aus irgendwie sieht das
so ein bisschen nach nach 3d effekte aus
finde ich auf jeden fall wenn so ein
kleines kind bei ihrer freunde oder
ihrem freund surfer sieht und sich
denkbar das will ich auch spielen ist ja
ganz nice wenn das dann auch
funktioniert diese videos von mir die
schau auch gerne mal ältere leute
deswegen wenn ihr überlegt einer tochter
der eurem sohn im tempel zu besorgen
auf keinen fall das hier es sei denn ihr
wollt es ärgern dann ist das eine option
so es geht los
würde der reagiert hierauf gar nix story
hat doch jetzt ein hindernis war das war
ja das habe ich mir schon etwas gedacht
an die die es interessiert als ich es
geschafft habe hatten wir 65 prozent ab
jetzt haben wir 28 prozent noch mal ein
kurzer blick in die kamera
also gesamt fazit es ist wirklich der
letzte schrott wahrscheinlich halt schon
sehr alt und das ist für mich auch kein
ssten 39 euro natürlich gibt es jetzt
sicherlich wieder einige da draußen
sagen ja alex aber du musst das auch
noch von der anderen seite sehen es ist
nicht jeder bereit oder es kann sich
nicht jeder mal eben ein tablet für 150
euro lässt das sehe ich auch vollkommen
ein und das setzt sich auch gar nicht
voraus oder so nur meine argumentation
dabei ist immer so was lohnt sich halt
überhaupt nicht wenn jetzt sagt er nehme
ich lieber das jetzt hier für 40 euro
anstatt 1 450 euro
dann ist das meiner meinung nach
herausgeschmissenes geld wenn ihr
unbedingt ein tablet braucht warte
lieber ein bisschen ab und kauft es dann
wenn ich irgendwann das geld
zusammengespart hab ich habe das jetzt
getestet an die die es interessiert und
es ist halt wirklich der letzte schrott
man kann nicht an spannenden videos
schauen es reagiert absolut nicht
schnell die meisten apps verbrechen
direkt auf die kamera die jetzt wirklich
keine große rolle spielt bei einem
tablet ist auch katastrophal aber ich
bin halt der meinung das teil ist schon
älter und damit kann man das vielleicht
ein bisschen entschuldigen und dadurch
kommen auch der preis zustande
naja leute das war's mit dem video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen gerne daumen
nach oben da das ein für weitere
produkte die ich testen soll ihr können
super gerne mal kommentieren oder mir
bei instagram schreiben was ich als
nicht das testen soll
ich habe einen fernseher gedacht keine
ahnung hab ich da was für eine ansonsten
schreibt mir das sehr gerne
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder gibt es ein neues video ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen
ciao